I think we definitely pay a lot more for
childcare in this country than we should
I wish somebody would do something about
it I wish I wish our president would do
something about it
onyx
I'm paying more for my daughter's care
per semester than I paid for an entire
term in college it's a lot of money
I will actually leaving my job of nine
years and going to stay home become a
stay-at-home dad
just based on the cost alone we're
paying a car note with the amount of
money that we pay for daycare we'd be in
a Porsche or something like that
childcare in the u.s. is expensive so
expensive that in many states paying for
someone else to care for your kid cost
more than college tuition of course
costs vary by your kids ages and where
you live but child care can be more than
seventeen thousand dollars a year for an
infant it didn't used to be this way
child care costs have risen more than 70
percent since 1985 we both have I call
them like normal people jobs where we
have great jobs we're well supported we
have good benefits but I couldn't afford
a daycare center I feel like we're like
stuck in this middle class piece like
we're not low-income enough to get any
services but we don't make enough money
to really be comfortable and so we're
kind of stuck for some parents the high
cost of childcare means dropping out of
the workforce to stay at home to watch
their kids right now I'm making about
45,000 so there's no use of me working
to have somebody spend time with my kid
but leaving the workforce can cost more
than just lost income it means lost wage
growth retirement savings and social
security over time this could mean the
loss of hundreds of thousands of dollars
it doesn't feel natural to leave my
daughter with someone else at such a
young age while I go do something that
isn't really all that fulfilling
choosing a childcare provider can also
be really
Russell because the quality of child
care can vary widely it really is you
know a reflection of you who you're
leaving your child with and how you want
them to grow and what they're learning
research shows that access to
high-quality child care increases
literacy rates and academic achievement
while decreasing future criminal
behavior but always the biggest thing
you know quality versus affordability
and a lot of people have to sacrifice
one or the other and it's usually
quality despite rising costs for parents
child care providers in the US are some
of the lowest paid workers in the nation
and in many states they need only a high
school diploma
compare that to France where half of all
early child care workers have
specialized degrees and are better paid
and in countries like France Denmark and
Sweden the amount parents are required
to pay is based on their income but so
far this is yet to happen in the US
where many families spend up to 40
percent of their income on child care
you want to you want to share what
you've learned and daycare so far what
about our ABCs it's that way
i I truly believe that if we're living
in a society where we need two incomes
for a family to sustain itself then we
need to think outside the box and we
need help in order to make that happen